thank you
hello I am Professor arm again
shut off your phones
open your portfolios
pull out something that will interest me
to your easel stand beside your work
stand proud
please
Alec Anderson
your Technique is obvious it looks like
a photograph thanks that wasn't a
compliment
tear it up
excuse me the drawing tear it up
I worked my ass off on this piece no one
would miss it
no way
alas
our first casualty
usually I go through introductions
before someone quits I didn't quit yes
you did you just haven't realized it yet
you can go
good luck
any fool
can learn technique even Master it
it doesn't mean anything if it doesn't
come from inside
I am not interested in the rules of Art
we are going to break the rules
then I want you to break them again
see how broken you can get
Dalton Lambert
yes Ma'am why in the hell would you
destroy a beautiful drawing like that
once more for good measure
wasn't so hard was it
good you must let go of your past
shed your skin in order to grow
I'll count backwards from 10 with each
number I want you to think further and
further into yourself
do not lift the charcoal from the paper
[Music]
draw whatever your soul brings forth
and experience that defines you
you've got to be willing to dredge up
your ugliest innermost thoughts
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
you have headphones on
machine is quite loud but you'll be able
to hear me
I'm gonna need you to stay as still as
possible throughout the procedure
you feel like you need to get out of
there
give the car bottle squeeze we'll give
you a break
you good
overjoyed
all aboard
hit this
foreign
[Music]
silence
well
Dr Brauer
what what did you say
Dr Brower what did you say
well
come on
um
okay can you let me out please
hello hey
can you let me out
[Music]
okay let me out let me out hey Dr Brown
Dr power let me out come on
come on get me out of here hello
hey
just let me out
let me out let me out let me out
Dr Brower
let me out
laughs
okay come on
Mr Lambert what's that you okay well
what's that what was it where did all
lights go out calm down
the whole lights went out and I got
stuck in there man and I saw
I said Lambert you've been asleep for 15
minutes you went right off
your MRI went perfectly
take your time and get dressed
come on through